views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
too many dollars
chasing too few goods
tonight on politics now republican
congressional candidate mark robertson
talks to us about his campaign inflation
immigration and his military background
it's going to get even more relentless
that the spending that we've seen so far
is just the tip of the iceberg piles of
money being spent on political ads while
las vegas could be ground zero for
spending this year
and a nursing shortage how nevada
joining an interstate agreement could
help ease the strain
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler former
president donald trump is in las vegas
this weekend stumping for republican
senate candidate adam laxalt and
gubernatorial candidate joe lombardo mr
trump held an event friday night at
treasure island for about 200 donors and
supporters he's already endorsed both
candidates laxalt and lombardo now the
event happened after we recorded this
program you can check eightnewsnow.com
for more on the former president's
speech
current governor steve siselek is
spending some of his war chest for the
campaign funding he's out with a new ad
called two economies
hotels are full unemployment's low and
our economy is rated best in america but
there's another story too housing prices
gas groceries all taking a toll
i get it
governor assistalet goes on in this ad
to tout the state's american rescue plan
spending on affordable housing and child
care his campaign has already placed a
million dollar general election ad
reservation joe lombardo's campaign the
republican they have responded it says
sisalak is all actually right on this
one there is a tale of two economies in
our country there are states whose
governors manage their economies well
throughout covet and those that didn't
the statement says nevada falls into the
latter category
so bottom line there's a lot of money
already being spent on political ads
here in nevada and unlv political
science assistant professor kenneth
miller tells us you're going to start
seeing a lot more i spoke with him about
money and nevada's races that have the
country's eye this year
all the funding that is uh filing in
campaign funding the ad revenue the
commercials are relentless
what are you seeing in terms of where
the money is coming from and where it's
going already here in nevada
well i think all you're right the
advertising is already relentless but
what i'm seeing suggests that it's going
to get even more relentless that the
spending that we've seen so far is just
the tip of the iceberg
so
if we look back to previous election
cycles where we had races in nevada that
were similar to this one in terms of how
close they were and what was at stake
nationally for them
we're
we're not even close to how much money
we're going to see eventually think back
to uh 2018 jackie rosen runs against
dean heller and in that race there was
65 million was spent on jackie rosen's
side and 38 million on dean heller's
side
two thirds of that money came from
outside groups that is independent
expenditure groups and that's probably
what we're gonna see here again this
time anywhere from two-thirds maybe as
much as three-fourths of the money is
going to come from these national
independent expenditure organizations in
terms of how much is going to be spent
2020 we saw even more than 2018 in terms
of spending where races like this one
had about 100 million dollars spent on
average
so we're not even close to that yet so
if you think you've seen a lot of
political messaging so far just wait
until you get to labor day
i'm sure most viewers will find that
profoundly fantastic um
you know that i guess that that speaks
not only to um
you know for those of us in nevada it's
an important race obviously but for if
these national organizations are
stepping in they see nevada as very
important that's always that's been the
case for the last several cycles
is it just the senate race or the
governor's race that's getting all the
attention or
does the money assign that it's it's
those congressional races too that are
going to get a lot of the focus and a
lot of the money
yeah we're going to start to see more on
the house races soon uh most likely uh
we have several house races this year
that are going to be very close
um
we have dina titus's seat used to be
very safe seat for her it's not as safe
anymore so she's going to need to
campaign she has mark roberson running
against her who he's probably going to
draw some money and he's going to be
active
we have of course suzy lee and april
becker that's already a pretty active
race and that's going to get even more
so we haven't seen much uh from nevada
four yet but that's par partially
because we're here in uh the southern
part of the state so we don't see as
much of that activity but
three out of four of our house races
are
gonna be in the ballpark of close and
two of them should be very close we're
gonna see a lot there uh the senate race
is gonna be the biggest one though in
terms of spending national outside
groups are most interested in that
they're frankly they're more interested
in the senate seat than they are who's
sitting in the governor's mansion you go
back prior to 2010 money couldn't move
around very easily now money can move
wherever the races are close and there's
only two other senate races besides
nevada that are considered this tight
that's arizona and georgia so
we're going to be the focus of attention
you can see our full discussion with
professor miller on 8newsnow.com
so now to the race for congress you just
heard it referenced in that last
interview former army colonel mark
robertson is the republican nominee in
congressional district one it was one of
the safest democratic districts in the
u.s but the boundaries were recently
redrawn now republicans think they have
a chance to unseat incumbent democrat
dina titus i spoke with robertson about
the race and the issues
let's talk a little bit about your your
background what is it about your your
military service your your business
career that you think
suits you well
as a congressman well i'd say there's
three things first i have deep ties to
the district my wife and i raised our
family in the first congressional
district
i owned a business in the district we
went to church in the district shopped
played i coached a little league in the
district so we have deep ties to cb1
two is i have national service i served
for 30 years in the army i enlisted as a
private and retired as a colonel one of
my last assignments was to the pentagon
where i served in the office of the
secretary of defense for policy so i've
worked on national level policy how
would you address inflation if you're
elected to congress good i have a degree
in finance and an mba in fact i taught
finance at unlv i know how the economy
works and i know how to fix inflation
it's not that difficult inflation is
when there's too many dollars
chasing too few goods we had
government spending
horrendous amount of government spending
printing borrowing and spending money we
didn't have and then we had a government
shutdown that shut down
our factories and so we weren't
producing the goods that people need
that will naturally lead to inflation so
would you support a balanced budget
amendment or a
make an enforcement of a balanced budget
and i guess looking back
what were your thoughts on the efforts
to put money into the system the ppp and
sort of the coronavirus pandemic relief
funding from the white house yeah well
there the audits are going on now about
all that money that was injected into
the into the system and so much of it
was wasted and fraud i mean we were
sending uh stimulus checks to people in
prison and and the stimulus checks
weren't targeted to the people who were
most injured it was just this broad
distribution of money to people
and many of those people didn't need it
i talked to members of people who work
for the government and they said i never
lost a paycheck i don't know why i got a
stimulus check let's talk about another
issue here that you mentioned is key you
believe in district one the issue of
immigration illegal immigration we've
seen some horrible stories from down on
the border the last couple of weeks
how do you think
illegal immigration is not only
affecting district one but the country
and what would you like to do about it
yeah so we see a flow
a a flood of drugs gangs and guns coming
across our borders i have i have a
personal friend who lost his daughter
to fentanyl
poisoning and that fentanyl is coming
across our border it's not just people
it is uh drugs and and guns and gangs
that are coming across those borders
those affect the people in cd1 so what's
the solution we gotta we have to uh
secure our borders we've got to finish
the wall and we've got to use electronic
monitoring and then we've got to give
the border patrol agents the people on
the ground the resources they need to
keep the criminals out of our country
once we've controlled our border then we
need to fix our broken immigration
system if you're elected into congress
is there any level of
abortion support federal funding or
anything along those lines that you can
that you are in favor of okay first time
unequivocally pro-life i believe um with
the majority of americans that there
should be limits on abortion that
abortion shouldn't be unlimited
um
and i i applaud the decision to overturn
roadway
roe versus wade not just because i'm
pro-life
but because it was the right thing to do
in our constitution even justice
ruth bader ginsburg said that there were
some issues and some concerns with how
the road decision was made so the the
road decision the overturning role put
the power back to the people where it
belongs it doesn't belong to the federal
government belongs with the people and
i'm surprised to see so many career
politicians complaining that power was
taken from them and given to the people
that's where it belongs
you can watch our entire interview with
colonel robertson and interviews with
other candidates at eight newsnow dot
com just look for the political news tab
a new monmouth university poll shows
most people are concerned about their
wallets in the direction of the country
the economy 48 percent listed either
inflation or gas prices as their biggest
worry right now those were also the
biggest concerns across a wide variety
of demographics abortion came in at 5
percent 57 percent also said the actions
of the federal government over the past
six months they say have hurt their
family
the biden administration has signed an
executive order on abortion access that
happened on friday morning the executive
order tells federal government agencies
to push back on efforts to limit the
ability for women to access federally
approved abortion medication or to
travel across state lines to abortion
clinics
next year on politics now finding more
nurses
there is a shortage primarily due to
people taking a break from the
profession
burn out
next on politics now the head of unlv's
nursing school talks about a new measure
which could help with a nursing shortage
plus a new federal operation to crack
down on a spike in violence
now
welcome back to politics now
early bill draft requests for the 2023
legislative session have been posted it
starts on february 6th the initial
drafts just have a rough outline at this
point though on the republican side
state senator joe hardy has a proposal
to amend the constitution to limit
property taxes state senator james
settlemeyer has a draft for a state tax
holiday it would kick in when the gas
prices plus the state tax rather gas
plus the state tax reaches a certain
price per gallon but the measure doesn't
specify a price assemblyman greg hafen
has a voter id proposal democrat state
senator dina neal has a proposal to
penalize school administrators who don't
follow the new pupil centered funding
plan it would make other changes to
school administration as well
another from state senator james
orenshall would toughen penalties for
catalytic converter thefts
well nurses have worked long hours in
tough conditions all throughout the
coronavirus pandemic and many are
leaving the profession because of it i
spoke with the dean of unlv's nursing
college angela amar we discussed the
problem and an interstate agreement that
could help
how much of a shortage is there right
now in southern nevada of nurses
there is a shortage primarily due to
people taking a break from the
profession
burnout right and we've graduated
consistently through the pandemic as
have the other nurse in school so we've
continued to produce the same amount of
nurses they've all been hired
immediately they're all on jobs but we
are seeing where new graduate
nurses or suddenly our newer graduates
are now
the experts on units because there's
this lack of depth of expertise people
who could retire retired and other
people have left and not that they're
not well trained certainly but there's
an experience level there that might be
lacking i don't know if lacking is the
right way to discover that is the gap
right i think that is the gap that you
went from having all these people who
were working and progressing and then
you lose this and so suddenly your newer
graduates are now the senior folk who
are trained in the newest graduate so is
there a solution or is it just sort of
uh
you know trial by fire
i mean i think that
we saw certainly the
nurses being made into commodities it's
like we need nurses we talk about beds
and you know how many beds in a hospital
but beds need nurses to work those
beds or else they're not really valuable
and we've gone from this thing of of
nurses for hire bringing in nurses from
other states we can pay them more our
nurses then leaving to work someplace
else to be paid more
i mean the recognition of
the the feeling value the feeling the
love from your home institution has felt
sort of lacking and there are strategies
that people can take to prevent burnout
that hospitals can use when nurses feel
valued when they have voice when they
have shared governance all those things
make people stay
on the job more so let's talk about
something that is somewhat political
something that was discussed a little
while ago in an interim committee uh
with lawmaker state lawmakers this idea
of a nursing licensure compact sounds a
little technical here but essentially
it's it's a group of states all grouping
together
to help share resources to some extent
can you explain what this
is nevada's not a part of it right now
that is not a part and we've tried
periodically and it looks like we may be
trying again the nursing compact
licensure compact is a way of making
i would say standardizing or upping the
game of nursing practice across the
country when you think about it nursing
schools are
educating students with the kind of a
core curriculum that our creditors
require
and we all take the same licensure test
to get our license but with each state
having their own rules agreements it
means that nurses work differently
across states and what we're really
looking for is a way to have nurses work
at the top of their license full scope
of license that really benefits patients
and so 37 states joining in this have
said we agree that we're going to have
this standard and that
all the states that are part of us agree
to this standard work with this standard
why aren't more states involved 37 means
there's a fair chunk of them that are
not part of this
can you at least touch on why there
might be some hesitation in the nursing
community to being a part of this
i think nurses as a whole
like the idea of of compacts some of the
concerns people have are
making are more about disciplinary
things so people are concerned about if
they're nurses who are problems in one
state then suddenly you've opened the
door for them to bring those problems to
our state they're um people often
verbalize that maybe we'll lose control
over what happens within our state
um
i would say 37 is well over half and so
and it's been a journey
probably since 2010 or something that
we've really been moving at how can we
make
nursing practice the same across the
country
and so um
most of the fears that people have the
data doesn't bear out and data doesn't
show that this is really a legitimate
concern
our efforts to speak with local nursing
unions and state lawmakers on this were
unsuccessful utah and arizona are part
of the nursing interstate compact
next on politics now stopping violent
crime the new federal operation to try
and crack down on crime spikes in major
cities
vegas good luck
you're watching politics now
the byte administration is facing
mounting pressure to address a spike in
violent crime in major cities alexander
limon explores the steps the
administration is taking to address that
and what officials would like to see
the justice department says it has been
working to combat violent crime and that
a 30-day operation carried out by the
u.s marshals service resulted in a large
number of arrests including of three
suspects in connection with the mass
shooting on philadelphia's south street
the justice department says in june
federal law enforcement arrested 1500
violent criminals through something
called operation north star which is an
example of our efforts to protect our
communities from violence
and gun violence attorney general
merrick garland says the operation
focused on criminals wanted for the most
serious offenses including homicide in
10 major u.s cities this initiative
reflects
the
anti-violent crime initiative that we've
had in place since the beginning of
2021. however officials say the country
continues to deal with crime issues
notably with ongoing mass shootings most
recently a gunman opened fire from a
rooftop on a crowd celebrating
independence day in highland park
illinois
so far authorities say seven people have
died 20 minutes from the house i grew up
in it's just another horrific reminder
of the violence and particularly the gun
violence that we face authorities say
that gunman has now confessed to the
crime and he had ar-15 style weapons
president biden and vice president
harris are renewing their calls to ban
assault weapons and that's a call that
lake county state's attorney eric
rinehart echoes
a ban of these types of weapons between
1994 and 2004 everything shows that
these types of horrifying devastating
incidents went down during that time
but right now there appears to be no
appetite among republican lawmakers to
ban assault weapons last month congress
did pass new gun laws that include
expanding background checks and
encouraging states to pass red flag laws
as well as dedicating more funding to
mental health
in washington alexandra limon
republican senate candidate adam
laxalt's annual bask fry is adding more
guests former acting u.s attorney
general under president trump matthew
whitaker is scheduled to attend senator
texas cruz from texas is also speaking
at the event this is held up in
gardnerville every august
next on 8 news now remembering 1 october
how you can weigh in on what happens at
the site of the worst mass shooting in
american history this is politics
weekdays on cbs
you're watching politics now
clark county leaders are now accepting
ideas for a permanent one october
memorial this is of course the the
healing garden
you can submit those ideas on the clark
county website the deadline is september
30th later this year a design team will
be chosen and a formal recommendation on
those plans could happen in late summer
next year clark county is also hosting
informational sessions about this
process later this week and next week as
well
this week in what to watch rent control
is on the agenda the city of north las
vegas has a special city council meeting
next tuesday to verify the signature and
signature on a culinary union-backed
rent control initiative it is being
dubbed neighborhood stability by the
union we will let you know how that goes
forward
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we thank you for joining us here of
course we're back with you next saturday
for all the latest in the political news
just head to 8newsnow.com
have a good rest of your weekend we'll
be back with you next saturday take care
[Music]